Oh, hold on.
I think the audio is all weird.
Give me a second.
Let me try this.
Wait.
No.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Hold on.
Give me a second.
Can you hear it twice?
Is it okay?
Give us a sign.
Only once?
Okay.
Every little thing has a different sound.
Start game has a sound.
Load game has a sound.
Options has a sound.
Yeah!
Scourge, it's your birthday!
I got some pizza.
Can you cast a spell on it to make it taste super delicious?
Of course!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday, Scourge!
Three months already?
What?
Three months?
Holy cow.
Also, let me know if it's too loud.
Wait, is it?
I can't tell which one you're hearing.
So I'm gonna put it here.
I can't tell.
It's a bit loud.
It's okay if it can be lower.
Is it loud or not?
Is it okay now?
Three months, gang!
So we are.
Yippee!
Three months!
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Welcome back, Master!
Lady!
Welcome to...
Eternal Darkness.
Sanity's Requiem.
Spooky game for spooky ghosts.
This is a game I have always wanted to play.
I feel like I've always seen it like, you know, back in the day.
I always used to see it at the store.
Like, the game store.
And be like, oh my god.
Did someone recommend this?
Because you like Metal Gear Solid?
It's the same company that did Twin Snakes, right?
But yeah, I would always see it at the store.
And I've always been a fan of horror.
So I was like, I'm gonna play it.
But I never had a GameCube until Metal Gear.
Yeah, Silicon Knights!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you for all the memberships, you guys!
Thank you!
Thanks for three months!
Actually, tomorrow will be a membership stream.
So...
Yippee!
It all comes back to Metal Gear.
Pretty much.
So I know, like, nothing about this game.
I know a little bit about, like...
There's a sanity meter.
And that's all I know.
Oh, and I also know...
Apparently you need to play the game three times.
Which, I don't know what's up with that.
We'll see...
What's going on.
Before we get to that point.
Love this game.
It's great to watch you play.
I can't wait to lose my sanity.
Yes!
My second favorite GameCube game behind Fire Emblem.
Wow!
Yeah, I really just wanted to...
I really just wanted to play something that I hadn't seen people really playing.
So I was just like, well, this has been on my list.
No better time than...
The present!
If I don't play it now, I'll just keep putting it off.
You know?
So...
Wait, you have sanity?
No, I have no sanity left.
Supra!
Let me know!
Thanks for the 10 gift!
And thank you!
Check off MGS.
Bench it on your bingo card.
Shut up!
TV table trade!
Thank you for the 10 gift!
And thank you!
Yeah, I have no sanity.
I hope you guys don't either.
We're all in this together.
Right?
Start the game!
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
That device?
What do?
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
But I need that.
But I need that it...
Um...
Just play in one sitting!
Obviously.
Uh...
Well, I'm looking at my...
Okay.
Um...
Speed run, baby.
We're just gonna go without saving.
Santo Pichi!
Wait.
You know what?
Okay.
I will figure this out later.
Yeah.
I will...
I will figure this out later.
No way.
Okay.
Flesh?
Hordy Hoar?
Bone.
Bound together with the oddest magical incantation.
This wretched book is where it all began so long ago.
Before time.
Before humanity.
I am Dr. Edward Royvus.
I am a clinical psychologist.
Oh.
I am also dead.
What!?
This is not my story.
Okay.
Nor even the story of the Royvus family.
Then why are you here?
It is the story of humanity.
Nintendo.
Believe it or not, as you will.
Your perceptions will not change reality.
But simply color it.
Humanity has been on the edge of extinction for two millennia.
What?
For that long?
And dependent on so few.
The guardians grow restless.
I have another thing why I've decided to play this.
Once again, near.
Again.
That's on the flesh!
Whether by fate or misfortune.
My family has crossed their path.
And they didn't take kindly to it.
Their attention turns to my granddaughter.
For she is the last of my line.
And the last hope for humanity.
Oh yeah!
She looks like...
She looks like Tomb Raider.
She's better now.
Oh my god.
She's got a gun?
Oh, there's a skeleton?
There's a skele- Man, all in my room!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Please!
Shoot the gun!
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Is this what happens when your sanity is low?
Shoot the gun!
Oh!
Nice!
Oh my god.
They're immortal.
Because they're skeleton.
May the rats eat your eyes!
Who is...
What is happening?
Grandpa!
Oh, it's all just a dream.
Oh, 3.33 a.m.
Let's go.
The witching hour.
Hello?
Miss Alexandre Roivas?
Um, yeah?
Who's this?
This is Inspector Legrasse of the Rhode Island police.
I'm sorry to disturb you, but there's been an accident.
What?
It was Grandpa!
I'll be on the next flight out.
Oh, okay.
The Roivas Family Estates, Rhode Island.
Oh my god.
Gumshoe.
Ah, Miss Roivas.
I'm pleased to meet you.
Her eyes.
I mean...
Oh my god.
Yes, I suppose so, considering.
Her eyes.
My condolences.
This is most unpleasant.
It's a shame we couldn't meet under brighter circumstances.
Yes, it is.
Can we get this over with, please?
Of course.
Yeah, straight to the point.
But I must warn you.
It's not a pleasant sight.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I'm prepared.
I'm prepared for anything.
I'm afraid there's not much to say.
What do you mean?
Is he dust?
What happened?
Is he like atomized?
What happened to his body?
Oh.
What do you mean there's not much to see?
What do you mean?
Miss Roivas.
Is that your grandfather, Edward?
Oh my god.
Yes, it's him.
He just slipped into jelly.
He's wearing a family ring.
Oh.
Not much to see.
That was like the whole body, man.
I don't know.
I don't understand.
Why are you showing me this?
Did he just smirk?
Can't you check dental records or something?
What is wrong with you?
I'm...
You're the one...
I'm sorry.
It's my job, lady.
You're the only living relative.
And no, we can't check dental records.
You were the one who said...
There's no head.
There's no head!
There's no sign of intrusion.
And there was certainly a lot of force used here.
I have never seen anything like this in my 20 years on the force.
We have no head.
There's no evidence except for the body.
And what's left doesn't say much.
We don't have a single clue.
Well, you better find out who did this.
Yeah.
I'm not leaving Rhode Island until you do.
There must be some clue in this old mansion revealing what happened.
I want answers.
So do I.
How could she tell if there's no head?
I wish I had some.
He wore the...
He had the ring on, apparently.
Two weeks later!
Oh!
Sh...
Shocked by her grandfather's mysterious death and frustrated at the incompetence of the local police, Alex vows to uncover the truth.
She decides to search the mansion, the place where Edward conducted his research.
If there was a tie to his past and possibly a tie to his murderer, it would be here.
What was I going to say?
Oh!
Another reason I decided to play this was because, like, the day I was trying to decide what to play, um, Nintendo put out, like, a, oh, a video.
Did you guys see, like, the Emeo thing, which is a, it was, like, hinting at, at, like, a horror game that looks like they're working on?
And I was like, I was like, you know, I think, I think Nintendo, like, has...
I'm talking here!
Excuse me!
Um, I think they have, like, the copyright to the sanity system in this, so I was like, what if they kind of, like, incorporate it, but now I think it's Bloober Team and I'm really disappointed.
Oh my god.
What is going on?
I don't have a flashlight.
Okay, this is combat.
I'm combat ready.
I have the, I have the slowest punch in the West.
What's this one?
Nothing?
Okay.
Um, how do I?
Oh, I can do this.
I can just punch normal.
Okay.
This is block then.
All right.
Nice clock.
I'm examining it.
Okay.
Is that Grandpa?
Grandpa!
Oh!
Portraits of the ancestral rooivus line, the foyer wall...
Line the foyer walls.
Wait.
So it's not...
It's not the rooivus line.
It's the...
The...
Portraits of the incest...
Ancestral...
Sorry.
I have to really emphasize the...
Ancestral rooivus line the foyer walls.
Their faces reveal a dark brooding edge.
There is something about each one that gives the viewer an unsettling feeling.
I feel very unsettled right now.
Wait.
Can I check the clock again then?
Oh, here we go.
A beautiful carriage clock.
The hands appear to be...
Nintendo sits on cool horror games like Fatal Frame.
Fatal Frame!
But, you know.
We still have these classics at least.
Just a membership.
The hands appear to be stuck, yet the clock continues to tick, with the time permanently set to 333.
There is a key in the back of the clock, presumably for winding it.
Oh!
Should Alex...
Look at the key.
Yes!
Oh!
Alex picks up the desk.
He picks up the desk clock and pulls the key from it.
However, there is something odd about the key.
It isn't for winding it at all.
It looks like a dresser key!
Ghosts are so rude.
Stop the voices.
I wish I could run.
Oh, here is another rooivus line.
I hear birds.
Ew.
Okay.
Bum bum.
Examine.
Oh.
I'm...
I'm trapped.
The last weak rays of sunlight fight the shroud of darkness.
It lends an eerie feel to the last few weeks' events.
As the sun sets, Alex will be alone in this house, with nothing but the spirits of old for company.
This is the original Luigi's Mansion.
Wait!
Where?
They didn't solve anything though!
The call of the mansion beckons to Alex, drawing her back to uncover the fact that family secrets it hides.
Alex will not leave till she has learned what happened to her grandfather.
I did not expect like a visual novel going on here.
It's beautiful though.
Okay.
What's this way?
Open door.
Oh my god.
God.
Scary.
What is this?
Grandpa?
A wooden plaque is fastened to the door, taking the place of the lock.
A colored sigil is carved into the wood above a wide slot.
The slot is just wide enough to insert a narrow blade?
What is going on in this place?
Whoa.
They even have like the lens flare.
Is this the kitchen?
What?
Grandpa, can I get a snack?
No?
Okay.
Nothing around here.
Interesting.
Hold left trigger?
Oh!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Grandpa.
Oh.
Grandpa, can you play?
A grand piano stands here, awaiting the hands of a decent musician.
Unfortunately, Edward never really lived up to that description.
And as such, the piano fell into disuse.
Skye!
Thanks for the tech gift.
Thank you.
Come on.
Oh, what's this?
Nothing?
Oh, she's got them Barbie heels.
They sound so good.
What is this?
Fascinating.
What is that up there, though?
Yeah, these.
The illustration features a collection of strange line designs related to each other in a cyclical manner.
There appears to be some significance to it, but it isn't particularly evident.
Okay.
Meow.
Which was over here.
I didn't go through this door.
Where did Grandpa die at?
In here?
This looks like where he died.
Oh, my God.
I'm scared.
Don't do that to me, game!
Oh.
What?
Nothing here?
Okay.
Grandpa?
Oh, my God.
Another person.
Another clock.
Oh, my God.
Hickory dickory dock.
This looming grandfather clock seems to stand ominously...
Katsu!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
...Ominously in the corner, gazing on this empty room with an almost patriarchal air.
Huh?
Use the left and right to adjust the clock hands.
Arigato.
Chuu!
I'm not going to adjust them right now.
Thank you!
I've been waiting for a Vtuber to play Eternal Darkness.
Thanks.
Irish...
wristwatch.
Okay.
So far, only a little scary.
Where did...
Why does Grandpa have such a huge house?
Wait.
Which way did we come through?
What's in here?
Oh.
Then what was the other one?
Here.
What?
Oh.
What is this?
A brass-framed mirror is set onto the wall.
The mirror's direction can be adjusted by the means of two crankshafts set below it.
Banger after banger after banger games.
Thanks, Zachary!
A curious device.
Is it related to the telescope in some way?
Should I...
No, it's not adjusted just yet.
Why is there a globe in the ground?
A globe cradled in a wooden frame.
There's so much...
There's so much stuff!
Yeah, this house has some fun stuff in it.
I know, right?
Its glossy surface is...
This is probably how Grandpa died.
He tripped over this globe in the ground.
Its glossy surface is painted in the likeness of an ancient map.
A lens is situated in the northern hemisphere above a label that reads, There be dragons here.
Dragons!
I feel like a dragon.
A dragon would be a pain in my side.
Okay, this is the same thing.
That adjusts...
Wait, so there's two of them.
Okay.
How do I look through it?
I don't think it would let me, but...
Oh, wait.
Maybe...
Here?
What is that?
Oh!
Okay.
Cool.
So there's three of...
Wait, huh?
I guess we're gonna see...
We're gonna start cranking it.
Never mind.
We'll come back.
Crank that soldier boy.
Superman now...
Whoa!
Watch me, you!
Oh, it's locked.
We have a...
We have a dresser key.
Oh my god!
Sorry.
The voices sometimes I just don't expect them.
They spook me really bad.
Lady.
Santa Claus.
I don't know if Santa was in our lineage?
Oh, do I have a...
It's locked.
I think I have a...
What's the word?
A...
I don't hear any voices.
Wait.
You guys have a weird smell, huh?
You guys don't hear the voices?
You guys are hearing the music though, right?
Right?
You don't hear the whispers?
The...
They only happen sometimes.
I guess we will start cranking it.
Anything you say, boss.
What does that mean?
What did I say weird?
Take your meds.
You haven't heard the...
All I hear is boom boom.
They happen sometimes.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you when it happens.
But yeah, we need to find the dresser.
I think.
I guess.
I also don't know how to use my inventory.
I hear the whispers.
You do?
We also need a sword.
There!
You heard that?
You heard it?
Care to demonstrate?
Just like that.
Okay, you guys are...
You guys are just gaslighting me.
You guys scare me.
Like that!
Right there!
Dresser key.
We need to find the dresser.
It's a euphemism for self-love.
Oh.
Of course.
It's not a day until I say something...
That I don't know what it means.
Okay, let's go back to the...
Alright, so there was the grandfather clock.
Down this way.
I don't think you know what gaslighting is.
What?
What are you talking about?
I basically invented the...
I coined the phrase.
Am I supposed to be seeing something here?
Hmm.
Over here?
Anything?
What I was trying to say earlier is I think I have a stamina meter.
Because she was like...
She was like heavy breathing after I was running a lot.
So here.
Oh.
Yes.
What if we move it to 3?
33.
Okay.
1.
2.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna do something else.
Okay.
2.
1.
Candles...
There's a spooky ghost in the bottom left corner!
In the left corner?
I don't think there should be a ghost in the left corner.
We got the dagger.
An ancient Roman weapon, a gladius, is on display above the fireplace mantle.
Another token of eclectic junk.
Pick it up.
Cool.
Skin?
A diabolic drawing of a stack of human bodies.
Oh my gosh, I was close!
Each one cemented into place.
What twisted psyche could have executed this drawing?
Though disturbing, it is meticulously rendered down to the subtlest detail.
The precise anatomy of fractured bones and the convolutions of spines and ribs entwined into a mesmerizing sight.
English is my second language.
I first speak ghost.
A painting of a jungle-shrouded building.
It seems to be a temple in Asia, perhaps from Thailand or Cambodia.
This is a bizarre drawing of a cyclopean city.
Say something in ghost.
I don't know.
They're insulting me, but you guys wouldn't understand, you know?
If you guys ever get a spirit box, ask, what are you eating?
And I'll be like, hungry for spaghetti.
Its immense architecture bathed in an unnatural fog.
The detail is incredible.
As Alex studies it, she can almost imagine the city's inhabitants.
Okay.
I think we have more things to worry about, Alex.
I think we've got more things to worry about.
Oh.
This looks like some kind of mask.
The face is serene and compo- That's what you call serene?
We don't speak zoinks.
The serene and composure with a faint hint of a smile tugging at the corners of the mouth and eyes closed in deep meditation.
The- This is serene?
I don't know.
Maybe I've never felt peace.
This gothic cathedral is silhouetted against a stark light.
The image is vicious and devoid of subtlety.
Every brush stroke echoes the spikes of the architecture, imbuing a violent feeling as though the building itself is a harsh imposition on reality.
A grim picture indeed.
It's a house!
Yo, it ain't that deep.
It ain't just a house.
Can't really see the cathedral.
Me neither.
It was so dark.
Serene bro looks like he's pogging.
I know, right?
What's this?
An aged page set inside a glass frame hangs on the wall.
An insane scribbling covers the page.
Incomprehensible to Alex.
Perhaps if Alex had some kind of tome, it could be deciphered.
Is that what this is for?
A large leather-bound antique book rests upon the cluttered desk.
We shall read it.
Done, done.
Oh, now it's bright in here?
What?
The dune?
The popcorn?
I had no knowledge of what was to come.
The popcorn bucket?
Nor did I care.
How the knowledge changed me, it will also change you.
As you read this, you will come to learn.
Learn fear, as I have.
Oh.
You, too, will come to understand.
Or you will perish.
Ooh.
Grandpa, maybe you should have locked this up.
To think that once I could not see beyond the veil of our reality.
A chosen one.
To see those who dwell behind.
My life now has purpose.
For I have learned the frailty of flesh and bone.
Flesh and bone!
Come on!
Yo!
Why are we in Rome?
What's happening?
What?
Augustus.
Wait, what just happened?
Our enemies did not have a chance.
Why did they switch?
Do you believe that it really exists, Centurion?
I do not doubt our Emperor's beliefs.
Or his orders.
But if we are to retrieve the artifact, then we must be strong.
Latin budget right now.
I suddenly know Latin.
Yeah, we all have become wiser today.
Come.
Pius Augustus.
Wait!
He folded so quickly.
No!
Augustus!
Don't listen to the voices!
Wait, why is he walking like that?
My guy is struggling.
Pius Augustus.
Oh my gosh!
Sake!
Thank you, Brother Silver-chan!
Thank you so much!
Come to us, Pius Augustus!
Paisagastas...
Such a fun name to say.
What is going on?
Oh my god, Stonehenge!
What is happening?
Oh my god, he went to the nether.
I'm Paisagastas!
Oh no!
Oh my god.
The dice on the floor is finally crafted.
Inlaid with golden gems that Pais can't identify.
A strong linear design is situated in the middle and is equally unknown to the Roman soldier.
Okay.
I'm Paisagastas.
What is that super chat?
One of my favorite games on the GameCube.
Oh, I got the thing.
Spooky game!
Thank you!
Thanks for the super chat!
Okay, I don't think there's anything here.
Nothing here.
We just have to scoop spooky skulls?
Look at all the skulls!
Oh yeah!
The shaft descends towards the next lower level.
A ladder is situated on one side of the shaft.
Okay.
Well, take it.
The ladder leads into the dank heart of the labyrinth.
Danger lurks beneath.
Yet Pais' courageous resolve does not buckle.
Should Pais climb down the ladder?
Yeah!
Uh oh.
Climb up?
Oh my god.
Wait, can I see in first person?
Okay.
I think that guy is gonna stand up.
Plus my lottery luck?
Are you sure you want me to do that?
Moe!
Jackpot!
Are you pressing triangle?
I'm pressing everything.
Oh, see?
I'm afraid of booby traps, but let's just walk.
I mean run.
He's got a blinky thing.
I knew they were gonna get out!
Oh my god.
Are they all gonna get out?
Don't hurt me!
Oh my gosh.
Health meter.
Thank you.
Sudden tutorial.
Oh my gosh.
Mini scooter, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
This meter represents life energy.
Every time a character takes damage, the level will get lower.
When it reaches zero, the character will die.
Okay.
This function allows the manipulation of inventory items within the current room.
Allow the current character to ready a weapon.
Okay.
This function allows the examination of objects within the inventory.
Press L or R allows switching back and forth between sections within the interface.
How do I get out?
B?
Maybe?
Oh my god.
Turn around!
Turn around, Pius!
Augustus!
Pius!
We...
We need to run.
We're...
Oh my god.
Pius!
Did I know there were three of you?
Oh my god.
Ouch!
There we go.
Nice.
Nice one.
Chop him up!
Don't let him walk again!
Oh, they're struggling.
Oh!
Nice!
Can I step out?
Oh, finish him!
Yeah!
What about these guys over here?
I'm walking so sad.
You guys not a problem?
Alright.
I'm gonna take this cube!
A strange granite block lies on the floor.
Alright.
It's mine now!
Baby Core, thanks for the gift!
Happy birthday?
Wait, who...
Whose birthday?
Oh!
Lily!
Can I get a happy birthday?
I just turned 30!
I can feel myself turning to dust!
You're just like the skeletons!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Lily!
Please!
Happy birthday to you...
Skeleton!
Nice.
There better not be anymore guys in the air!
Oh!
No one forgot us!
Slice and dice!
Oh my god, run away!
Finish him!
Nice.
I think I'm getting the hang of it.
Oh, I can finish this guy too.
I'm taking all your blocks!
You can't stop me!
This is how I learned how to read!
Strange granite block.
Pick it up.
Is this the same game?
I know, right?
Oh god.
Uh oh.
You guys.
Oh god!
There's a lot of guys!
Pick up the block!
I think it's time to leave.
Did he just look at that too?
Did we just react to the same thing?
Coward!
What are you talking about?
There's a skele-man right here.
Can I sneak?
Why can't I walk?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I can't see where I'm going.
This is kinda bad.
Ouch!
Take his arm!
Take his body!
Take him!
Finish him!
I'm gonna go where he was going.
Oh, nevermind.
Did they say Pius?
They're obsessed with me!
The bars across the door block Pius's exit from the room!
Is there another skele over here?
Oh.
Okay.
I think I hear a skele.
Oh my god.
The angles.
The camera angles are seriously killing me right now.
Pius, I'm scared!
Pius!
Run!
Run, Pius!
Pius!
I think they're gone.
Oh, he's not gone.
Ha!
Fist attack!
Attack!
Don't die, Pius!
Pius, you gotta live!
You gotta live, Pius!
You gotta live!
Pius, you have to live!
Don't hit the wall, Pius!
Pius!
Get one hit in, please.
Pius.
Just one hit.
No, finish him.
Finish him.
Kill off that guy.
Okay.
Pius is a changed man.
He fears nothing now.
I don't have a purple one.
Wait, the purple one is my blade!
Oh, just kidding.
Who am I hearing?
Oh, I think I'm hearing the flames.
If I grab that, am I gonna...
Something's gonna happen.
The wall is predominantly decorated with a strange symbol carved into the granite.
Cut into the wall is a square hole lined with the scratches as though something has been removed from it.
Face your cube fear.
I put all of them in though, right?
Probably?
Only two kids.
My parents wouldn't let me play this one in Dead and Alive Beach Volleyball.
I was told they were both just scared.
I think maybe Dead or Alive would cause a scarier awakening than anything.
Okay, I think I just put them all in.
Alright, let's grab the cube.
Women are pretty scary, I'm not gonna lie.
Especially when they're sexy.
Okay.
Time to put it in.
Wait, it won't let me.
How do I get to the menu again?
How do I... Oh, here.
Oh, okay.
Use.
Ah!
Just like that.
Okay.
Poor men scared of pretty girls.
You're not.
What if I put it in the wrong hole?
What if I... What if I... What if I put blue into red?
Wait, that was red, right?
Oh, thank goodness.
Whew!
This is really cute.
A dorkable ghost in the bottom right of the screen.
Can you tell her that?
I don't know.
Here we go!
Avatar, the last airbender!
Yippee!
Just run for it, Pius.
Pius Augustus.
Just run for it.
Don't let any scaly men tell you otherwise.
Run!
That's me!
They really are obsessive.
Wait, am I gonna have to fight myself?
What is going on?
Pius, you must prove your worth by destroying this statue.
Pressing R will enable Pius to select which target to attack.
Releasing R slightly and then pressing it again will cycle between multiple targets.
Pius can attack specific body parts while locked onto an enemy by moving the... the... the... the... the... stick?
And pressing A.
Use up to attack the head.
Left and right to attack the arms.
Okay.
Oh!
Yippee!
Okay.
I had to destroy myself.
I'm going... I'm not leaving.
I'm going deeper in.
It's a ghost.
Can't you tell skeletons to leave?
Probably.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
I feel that I attack faster if I'm not... if I'm not locked in though.
Get them all!
Take them out!
Ouch.
Oh my god.
Pius, don't die on us.
Pius!
Pius Augustus!
Pius Augustus, please!
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Finish him!
I think he's... I think he's... finish him.
There we go.
Pius!
Oh no!
He's bleeding my bed!
What is this?
A button attached to a small pylon softly illuminates the room.
A bizarre energy seems to radiate from it.
Push the button.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
I can barely even run.
Pius, you're not gonna make it.
Why is there no way to defend myself?
He just needs to...
He just needs to radiate.
Press for a second.
It's just a...
It is a flesh wound.
Pius Augustus about to be Pius Adustus.
What is this thing anyway?
Health?
No?
Okay.
Push the button.
Oh.
Is this gonna send me home?
Wait, this might send me home.
It looks kind of similar to the thing that we came here with.
There we go.
Um...
Pius ain't looking so hot, you guys.
Pius looks like he's about to throw up.
Pius is...
Pius said, but it was beer o'clock.
Do I pick one?
What's this?
Shaped like a delicate dome, a pale blue statuette floats gracefully above the pedestal.
No, no, no.
Oh my gosh.
It's choose your starter Pokemon.
An effigy resembling a warped angel shaped from dark green emerald hovers effortlessly above the pedestal.
A strange sculpture resembling a red-clawed worm.
Does it?
Mysteriously float above the pedestal.
Hmm...
I think because I'm green.
I should pick green.
Also, I like the warped angel.
Pius Augustus, what powers do we grant upon you?
Oh.
You're okay.
He's seeing...
He's seeing green.
No, Pius!
Pius Augustus, no!
Eons have passed since then, and I have learned much.
I haven't learned anything.
I was once as naive as a child, but now my mind is sharp.
With the power of Xelatoth, I can now read the thoughts of others and make them raving mad with a mere sight.
I have a suggestion.
Face me, and you shall surely perish.
What?
Guess it ain't easy being green.
Tome of Eternal Darkness!
Yippee!
Um...
Can we read it now?
Strangely, with the Tome of Eternal Darkness in her possession, Alex can read the page!
It is a chapter page from the Tome itself.
Yes.
The Binding of the Corpse God!
Xelatoth turned Pius into an influencer.
What do you mean an influencer?
Yo!
Corpse God!
Oh, wait, I didn't read this before.
A small shrine of candles.
Their placement appears to be very deliberate, matching the etchings on the table and the wall's illustrations.
The candles are unlit.
Okay...
None of this has changed, so...
I guess we can leave?
It's so dark.
Even for me, it's hard to see.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
What am I going to have to fight?
I have the slowest ever!
If you suffer from VTuber syndrome, ask your doctor if Xelatoth is right for you.
Okay, so now that we solved the grandfather clock, and we have the Tome...
Oh, wait!
We have the dagger!
Let's go do...
I think it was...
It was this way.
Let's go do the dagger that will let us into the other room.
In here, I believe.
I believe.
Oh, yeah.
I thought it was purple before.
Oh, do I need to use it?
Oh, so now I have to address your key...
Second floor key?
When did I get that?
Under scale.
Thanks for three months!
It was purple before.
Ah...
Shoo...
Alex places the blade in the slot, but feels it push back.
It is as if the magic of the blade does not fit the lock.
Let's go to the second floor since I apparently got a second floor key...
and I don't know when I got that.
The key comes apart in the lock.
The key to the second floor is broken.
Perhaps there is a way of repairing it.
Yippee!
Uh...
It's saying that there is...
TV table tray gifted to memberships.
Thank you!
I think it's a little delayed, but thank you guys!
Yay, we got the broken key!
Yay!
Wait, how did they investigate this mansion?
How did they investigate the mansion if they didn't have access to the second floor?
No wonder they didn't solve anything.
What if the murderer is in the second...
It's right up there!
And we don't know about it!
Okay, maybe here.
I like this room.
It's nice and bright.
It's pretty.
It's so cool.
Wait!
Is this the dresser?
No way.
Oh, never mind.
Tizana!
Welcome to membership!
Bye, bubboy!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you, guys.
I don't know why I'm shifting here.
Hmm...
Like it doesn't... I don't see anything moving.
What's up with that?
Maybe I need to still wait on this one.
Hmm... Oh, what was that?
Examine?
Oh!
In the warm glow of candlelight, the Roivis family tree hangs from the wall.
Shadows flitter across its surface, obscuring the detail.
If one looks closely, the family's secrets are revealed.
Oh my god!
There's a dead man!
I saw the secret!
Is there anything on these shelves?
I didn't see anything.
Also, I noticed that she, like, does that thing in old games where they, like, look at what you need to observe.
Tax fraud.
What am I examining?
Oh!
The books in this corner seem to focus on the supernatural.
The writings of Poe, Lovecraft, the poetry of Blake, the art of Bosch...
Everything with a tie to ethereal horror or fantasy.
It is all here.
A reference library to the arcane.
Was this Alex's grandfather's secret hobby?
My grandpa was a freak!
Let's go!
Was there anything that I couldn't read before?
Now I have my special tome.
My special book.
Wait, what is this?
Oh!
I cannot say what was the true beginning, nor am I sure of its end.
So perhaps here is the best place to start.
Okay!
I am reminded of ideas I first encountered in Sir James George Frazer's book, The Golden Bough.
A study in magic and religion.
The Golden Bough.
We are overwhelmed by a very human need to weave a web of meaning where there may be none.
Since time immemorial, ancient peoples have dressed up their lack of knowledge as gods and demons.
You calling them stupid?
I have discovered that sometimes...
the fates of gods and mortals intertwine...
and legends are born.
The Golden Bough.
Oh!
Thy time is done, great ancient.
Thy time.
Forever in shadow will you be master of chaos.
And to fade to nothing in obscurity will be thy fate.
My master has planned no millennia for this day.
It is the true chaos of all things that you now must be entombed amongst the beings of flesh and bone.
Oh!
You have a great monument here, Mount Turok.
It is a pity that no one will ever recognize it.
That's... that's our guy!
May the darkness claim thee, quarreling chaos and damned beast.
No longer will thy reign be kept over the ancients.
You have kept imprisoned.
The voice of the Fury.
Thou hast seen the last of this world.
He's voiced by the Fury?
This guy, Pius Augustus?
No way!
And Big Boss.
What is going on?
No!
Don't hurt him!
Not even these mythical fables can keep me amused.
There has to be something to do around here.
I only wish something that fantastic and of higher purpose could happen to me.
Oh, let's have it.
Let's let it happen.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Um, the door just shut on its own.
The door is firmly closed, sealing the temple.
Perhaps there is another exit somewhere inside?
Uh-oh.
I have my weapon.
My short sword.
Wish granted.
Good job, girl.
You manifested it.
This is...
Also, her cheek.
Her singular cheek is out.
Um...
The statue of a goddess delicately sculpted from sandstone.
It casts an alert eye over...
Oh, sorry.
Everyone who enters the temple.
There is a strange necklace around its neck.
Should Elia take the necklace from the statue?
Um...
Hmm...
I don't...
This game has tons of Metal Gear voice actors?
The girl you are now is Mei Ling?
Wait, I can hear it, though.
No, but yes.
Probably not, but sure.
Okay.
Strange necklace!
We're stealing from...
Uh-oh.
This necklace can be used to heal Elia.
Make sure that Elia does not move when the spell is being cast.
Oh.
We have health!
Ten times!
Okay.
I can't see anything.
It's so dark.
I'm just casually walking around this temple.
Whatever.
Oh no.
I see them on the ground, you guys.
Look at all of them!
They're all going to come to life!
Oh!
I hit the cutscene.
What were you doing chilling in here that you didn't know that they could...
That there were bodies in here too?
I'm just saying.
These guys are so...
So, we're gonna come to life.
Okay.
And then this.
Yeah, the sun is over there.
So that's where the sun is.
I get it.
I don't do anything here though, right?
Oh gosh, don't come to life.
Don't raise.
Don't lift.
What are you doing?
No way.
Why were you chilling in here again?
I don't understand.
It's kind of a sick beat.
Oh my god.
What did I just press?
Don't press that.
No!
Why are you pressing all the buttons?
You idiot.
Don't press anything.
Elia, please.
You're making me nervous.
Look how many dead...
Oh gosh, I have to walk over this one though, don't I?
Okay.
What just happened?
I'm out of here.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Ew.
Oh, he's...
Oh.
When located by creatures, a sanity loss occurs, causing a decrease in the levels of the sanity meter and the character's supposed green.
Beware!
Sanity loss affects perception and eventually health.
Um...
Wait, so...
I...
Being located by creatures...
Oh my god.
I'm just jumping into the thing.
Oh gosh, Elfrid, thank you!
That's why you're Ace Detective Minto, because you asked the obvious questions the other cops didn't know.
I'm suddenly thrown into a thing!
Tutorial jump scare.
Oh my gosh.
He doesn't know where I am.
Oh my god.
I'm trapped.
Oh.
Uh.
Oh, please.
Ouch.
Performing a finishing move on a creature recovers sanity.
Oh yeah!
Oh, I had to kill him.
Finish him!
Oh.
Finish him?
Ah!
That was low.
That was a low blow game.
It wouldn't let me finish him!
There was no thing to finish.
There was no, like, little thing.
Engraved on the floor is striking design featuring a brightly burning sun.
Why?
Oh.
Another bronze.
Nice.
A bronze necklace.
Hold on.
Let me turn on my...
My fan.
It's getting hot in here.
Bronze necklace sitting atop an ancient clay urn.
Um.
I'll take that.
I'm just gonna...
Just gonna take every...
You know what?
This...
This temple has done no service for me.
I'm gonna take everything.
Awesome.
We can see her, like, up close now.
She is so cute.
Look at them cheeks!
Oh!
Yeah!
She is so cute!
The sun is in the middle.
Oh, the design on the wall appears to depict the time of the day.
Perhaps the candles do too.
Press Y, A, X to light or extinguish the candles.
Okay.
So...
Oh.
My bad.
Um.
Oh, okay.
So, I...
I'm extinguishing this one.
There we go.
Okay.
So, I just wanna put something on the ground.
A...
Oh!
How...
Uh...
Do I need to do more?
No?
Nothing else?
Let me in, please!
Door is open slightly but not enough for Elia to go over it.
Just...
Just use your arms.
It's jammed.
There were two that were jammed, though.
What was the other one?
Oh, gosh.
Alright.
Hey skellies.
Don't come waking up.
Okay.
Now ain't the time.
Oh my god.
I think the thing just popped again.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Alright, careful.
You know what, Elia?
Wait.
Which would be...
You know what, let's only hit one and not two.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
Nice.
I'm kind of a genius.
Finish him!
Oh gosh.
Run.
Finish him!
Oh shoot.
I got his arm!
I got his other arm!
I got his head!
Finish him!
Yeah!
That's right.
Oh my god.
Take his arm out.
Take his other arm out.
Or finish him.
Yeah!
We did it, baby!
Well this is... how it's supposed to look.
She's gaming.
I was first intimidated by the system.
But actually it's not so bad.
Is there anything else over here?
I know that this...
Is this door closed or something?
The door is now closed, preventing Elia's passage to the other side.
What did I miss over here?
I should have explored before I grabbed...
Before I stole!
I can't see anything.
Oh!
The triangular design is carved into the floor.
The etched grooves are filled with colored sand.
The symbols appear to be related to each other with having one precedence over another.
You got all that information from... that?
Where am I supposed to go though?
Eat the sand.
Was there anything in here?
Oh my gosh.
I almost stepped on this one.
I didn't step on it though, right?
Look at this guy.
He looks like he's just...
He looks like he's...
He's just like...
Is she gonna notice?
Relation of the three gods is akin to rock, paper, scissors.
We did this one.
And we got the other necklace.
Hold on.
Oh, let me see what this does.
Can't use it.
There's also a map.
Okay.
Cinema.
Kinda...
Do I use it here?
No.
Maybe...
Down here?
Oh gosh.
I have to go all the way through here again.
Oh my god.
Why is it pop?
Shimmy.
Shimmy passed.
Don't press the button.
There's a check option.
Oh, that's right.
What was it?
That's right.
A well-crafted bronze necklace.
Resplendent with glowing gems.
Oh.
What are we?
That didn't really tell me anything though.
Anything in here?
Blue, red, red, red, green.
Hmm.
Da, da, da.
Candles do too.
Oh mama.
Where did you get a necklace before?
You guys are so smart.
You want this one?
It's prettier.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm ready.
To fight.
Maybe.
I'm scared.
These guys scare me.
It's a sunset.
Engraved on the floor is a striking design featuring the sun...
Oh, sorry.
Sunrise.
This one is correct.
The save?
Well, okay.
So I had a bit of an issue with my...
I gotta go find a proper...
A proper...
What's the word?
Memory card.
Because I don't have one.
So I can't really save right now.
So I just said we'll...
We'll deal with that later.
Probably.
Why?
Am I coming back?
Am I coming up to a boss or something?
Or is that what you're hinting at?
Is that what you're hinting at?
I'm coming up to a boss?
Don't scare me.
Oh.
Rogue-like.
I'll just...
I'll just fix it later.
Again.
I don't...
Oh.
He is gross.
atives.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh.
My gosh.
He hits hard.
Oh.
I got his hand.
Uhh.
He hits really hard.
Nice.
Got him.
Oh, what?
He grows his hand back.
That's fucked up.
That's messed up.
Finish him!
Oh
my god.
Yikes.
Striking design featuring a starry sky filling the heavens.
Yeah, I can heal, that's right.
I think I just sold my soul.
Oh, we gotta extinguish everything.
This one... and this one.
It's so dark.
Yeah!
Good job selling your soul, thank you.
I see them.
I see the traps on the ground.
Oh my gosh, this one is tight though.
What is this?
A small pedestal covered with decorative etching stands before the wall.
The blowgun upon it must have some sort of...
special significance for it to be the focal point of this display.
Spooky stick, yeah.
Alright, what's on this side?
Nothing.
Everybody only cares about the blowhole, I guess.
Should I take the blowhole?
My first M&M postcard arrives in Germany.
Yippee!
Blue enemies die, they explode.
The more of them together, the more damage the explosion...
Oh!
So the enemies have like different...
Different...
What's the word?
Uh, powers, I suppose?
Oh, it said blowgun!
I kept saying blowhole, I'm so sorry.
It's a blowgun.
No!
Oh my gosh, be careful, don't die by your own weapon!
I should not have taken the blowgun.
I hear Mei Ling so much now.
Oh my god.
What's happening?
Who are you?
Oh, shoot.
I think they noticed me.
I think I need to get out of here.
I think I need to leave.
I think it's time for me to go.
I think it's time to skedaddle.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, skedaddle!
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
I think it's time for me to leave.
I think it's time for me to...
That was me, right?
Oh, rip the guy!
There was a guy, you're right.
I should go help him, right?
How do I attack?
He's fine, right?
Oh, shoot!
Oh my god.
Whoa, what's going on?
Oh, I have a certain number.
I think this game is hard.
Might be time to leave.
I'm chilling.
Yeah, I'm just going to chill.
Until the other guy leaves.
I don't have a good weapon anymore.
I shouldn't...
I should have never taken this stupid...
Oh my god.
Punch him!
Oh!
Uh oh.
This is bad.
Oh shoot.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Run, run, run.
Oh, he died.
He died.
Oh...
I did it.
My sanity...
I think I did it.
Let me actually finish him so that I can get the sanity back.
Okay.
We're good.
Everything's fine.
You're making decent progress if you're here by the time I got home from work?
Oh, really?
I think I'm just a genius.
Wait.
Description.
I saw it.
There was a... details, but it disappeared.
Oh, examine.
This mural depicts a skeletal demon befriending the ancient Khmer people by denouncing one of their fertility gods.
Yeah!
Down with babies!
Up with demons!
Yeah!
I see it.
They say, yeah, we hate babies.
Yeah!
Celibacy!
Demons!
Demons are like, yeah, screw those babies.
Understandable.
Yeah, we hate babies!
I love abstinence!
Whatever happened to the guy that... I'll be honest, I thought the guy was me.
The guy that was crying in that other room?
Did I really get him killed?
Aw, my bad man.
Oh, what's this here?
Is there anything here?
Oh.
What is this?
There is a hole in the device as though something can be inserted.
Perhaps a key or a lever.
My blowgun!
Obviously.
Bad end result?
No!
It's fine, probably.
Wait, this is a different room, right?
Yeah, this is a different room.
How am I supposed to get around this trap?
I don't think I'm supposed to.
I'm supposed to heal Maeve.
My health is still at half, but she's acting like a little baby about it.
You're all set.
Just selling my soul.
Okay, now it's the only... Now it's just the one that I have to walk through.
Oh shoot.
Where did they... Ouch!
Ouch!
Where did they come through?
I can't tell at all.
Okay, I think I'm alright.
Oh my gosh.
I was not alright.
Oh my god.
I have to walk through these!
This is so messed up.
Okay.
Alrighty.
I have to walk through this one too.
Oh, the girls are fighting.
I think they're dumb.
I'm just not gonna examine that.
Can I let them fight?
They won't notice me, right?
Nice.
Oh, I think he's noticed me.
Oh my god.
Run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run.
He changed colors.
Oh, I didn't do that.
Wait, why is he dying?
Oh, did I poison them?
Oh, interesting.
Patooy!
Interesting.
Okay, I was wondering why they were taking damage sometimes.
What is going on here?
Oh, my bad.
The mural depicts one of the ancient Khmer deities being tortured and killed by a skeletal demon.
Wait, is this Pius?
Is that Pius right there?
Was he in the one before?
And that's the thing that he...
Oh, it's like the thing that he... well, it kind of looks like it.
Pius my Oshi.
Okay, she keeps looking up.
Makes me wanna...
Okay, so we came from this door.
I remember, so we gotta go this way.
It's Pius!
Thank you, thank you.
Choo!
Mei Ling!
Oh, my god.
My screen is like... do you see this?
If you die without saving, you'll need to start the game all over again.
Mint, try to think ahead and consider what might go wrong.
Oh, my god, my screen.
Oh!
This is...
Wowie!
This is the room!
Oh, my god.
Hello?
He's asleep.
He's snoring.
Don't mind every eyeball being open.
Stop.
Don't go near it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Why
is she chilling in here?
I'm so...
So, you are reduced to feeding on flesh and bone.
How the mighty have fallen.
Ooh, get called out.
Surely fester for millennia to come.
A slow...
Don't go near it.
And torturous hate for thee.
You had best leave, young fool.
Okay, I will.
Or you'll find yourself as food for the dead god.
I'm out of here.
Oh.
How do I get out?
Can you help me?
Ah!
Um...
I'm taking...
You are one of the chosen many.
Flesh and blood.
Huh?
It is now your destiny to fight the eternal darkness.
Oh!
She's just passing out.
I give you a gift in return for an obligation.
Uh-huh.
The gift is your life, sweet dinosaur.
The obligation...
This other thing?
Is this.
You hold one of Mantarok's hearts.
Oh.
The essence of a corpse god.
Ew.
The sum that is a source of great power.
From those people, you must invent it.
I didn't ask for this.
You must use it to destroy it with little brightness.
I promise your world has left anything.
It looks gross.
It looks...
Guard it well.
Oh, God!
This is gonna humble off!
Wait!
Help!
Excuse me, sir!
Where did you go?
The metal staff is held in the arms of the statue.
So, can we switch weapons?
Is that what's going on?
Or...
Or rather like...
If I wanted to keep one...
Oh, my God.
If I wanted to keep one weapon, could I or do I have to switch?
Wow!
We can look at him!
Metal staff...
Stop!
You guys are more brain-rotted than me!
Ew...
The inside is like...
Hot breath.
What is this?
We gotta add a new emote before we get gross.
Maybe we do need a disgust emote, do we?
Okay.
I'm going.
What's over here?
Oh, I can look at him.
I'm frozen.
I look like...
They just took a picture of...
Like...
Bigfoot?
What?
I like orange as much as I like this game.
Thanks, Rude.
I hope you like it too.
It was one of my favorites to get through all the endings.
Yeah, I am curious about that.
Not quite sure how I want to approach that yet.
A statue of a human female bears witness to the monstrosity that fills the room.
The porous stone of its body is covered with the effluvio grime that messes with it.
The manta rock has secreted over the years.
Oh.
I know there's probably going to be someone that's like, It should have been me.
Oh, yeah.
I want your...
nasty stone.
Or nasty...
whatever all over me.
It should have been me.
What's over here?
Same thing?
Oh, yeah.
Give me your effluvio grime.
We should bring that kind of language back.
I don't even know what effluvio means.
But I just know some sicko out there is just like, It should have been me.
It should have been me.
Sakuna!
Effluvio grime, baby.
A door of formidable size seals the vault.
A stylized design resembling the creature that dwells within the room.
What do you mean the creature that dwells within the room?
It's carved into the stone.
What do you mean by that?
Like, oh, this room?
Can I use the staff?
No.
What do I do here now?
Means this guy.
Okay.
Wasn't sure if it meant...
Oh, that just looks like the sun up there.
Okay.
Am I going back?
Time to leave.
With my staff.
Does the staff...
Oh, shoot!
No, no, no!
Wait, I...
Oh, I can't equip it.
It's not a weapon.
Basically means stinky.
Effluvio.
Let's have no booby traps.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, my God!
Where am I?
Just run.
Just getting out of here.
Bye!
What's with the music?
Are there guys in here?
Please, say no.
They are going to step on something.
They are going to really mess something up for me.
I can't tell.
Oh boy, the Dutch angle.
Wait!
Oh dang it.
I thought I could walk through it.
Oh my god.
Oh shoot, they noticed me.
Do you think they are getting attacked?
Or do you think they are getting sliced and diced by this thing?
Oh god, they are starting... Oh my god.
What's going on?
What's happening?
I think I hear them still walking around.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Everything is happening.
I think I just have to go through it.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
My feet.
My everything.
Okay, I guess the guys died.
Which is great for us.
I think.
Oh.
Well, it would be great.
This looks like you could go around it, doesn't it?
Doesn't this look like you could avoid it somehow like this?
Who's talking?
Hello?
Me?
I'm looking pretty.
I don't care about you guys.
Okay, I'm just going to run for it then.
I'm scared though.
Accidentally.
Okay.
Setting off a trap is what I was going to say.
Oh shoot, oh shoot.
Oh my gosh.
Did I get hurt?
Where am I supposed to go?
Am I just backtracking all the way?
There's no way.
I have to backtrack so far.
I'm just running through things though.
Ah.
Oh my sanity.
Oh my god.
No.
Oh my sanity is so low.
That's why.
Oh shoot.
Step over the pressure plates.
Yeah, you know.
That would be great.
Oh shoot.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah, we have to kill to regain sanity.
You're right.
Oh my gosh.
If I could find a guy to kill.
What's going on?
What am I looking at?
Hello?
Oh.
Oh, this is my...
My sword.
What's going on?
This is where the guy was.
Maybe he was part of my low sanity.
She looked right at...
She's looking at me.
It's kind of freaky.
I wish I could get my sword.
Oh, I can pick it up.
Can I fix it somewhere?
Shut up.
It is completely useless.
You could have fixed it if you save the guy.
No way!
Oh man.
Okay.
All right.
If anybody wants to backseat on where I need to go, that'd be great.
I think we're going to have to go kill some guys in here.
Oh shoot.
Run, run, run.
Oh, shoot.
Just poison them.
Poison each guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Poison them.
Oh, he's down.
He's down.
Finish him!
Get him!
Hey, hey!
I was trying to do a move here, okay?
God!
No!
You're ruining my show!
You're ruining my... You're ruining it for me!
Oh my God.
Please leave.
Please.
Oh, please.
Oh, stop hugging me.
Please stop hugging me.
It's icky and gross.
Finish him!
There we go.
There's one.
There's two.
And let's get this guy.
Oh my God.
We're gonna have to heal though.
Maybe I should heal again.
Just in case.
It doesn't give you so much health.
That's okay.
Alrighty.
Okay.
Sanity up.
Oh, here we go.
That's right.
I forgot about this.
What the... Okay, perfect.
The metal staff!
We did it!
I forgot about here!
He probably wasn't real anyway.
Oh, I have to go all the way back.
Okay, this is fine.
This is fine.
It was this way, right?
Yeah.
Girl has... girl does not care.
Girl has zero cares ever.
I love chanting.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, shoot.
My toes.
I can't see.
Ouch!
Please.
Oh my gosh.
This is so bad.
Alright.
Here we go.
Run!
Just run!
Ouchie ouch!
Oh, shoot.
I forgot about these guys over here.
Bye!
What?
What are you saying?
Was that me?
Who did that?
Just go.
Just get out of here.
Everything's shaking.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's okay.
Catch your breath in here.
I think it's safe.
It's probably safe.
It's fine.
She's going to Lulu?
Me too!
Oh!
Yeah, I agree.
Instead you will die.
Where is the essence of Mantarok?
Um, in my tummy.
Uh-oh.
They're coming at me slowly.
Oh, they're being really gentle with me actually.
Where is it?
I will not ask again, child.
It's in my tummy.
Very well then.
You will succumb to the horrors of oblivion.
No!
Chapter Cup.
Whoa!
Freaky!
Oh.
How did they...
A small shrine of candles.
Their placement appears to be very deliberate, corresponding to the etchings on the table and an illustration upon the wall.
Some of the candles have been lit!
Oh, now which ones do I extinguish?
That was the end of her chapter, alright.
What the hell is going on in this game?
What is going on in this game?
I still have the broken key.
Thank you!
Chu!
What if Alex's grandpa just did that and he died of natural causes?
Yeah.
The beheading?
Totally natural.
Is there... Hold on.
Oh, I see it!
I see the sun up top.
So maybe just... those... Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Okay, I see it.
I was like looking for it.
Okay, so this one and this one.
There we go.
With the correct sequence of candles being lit, a hidden panel opens.
There is a message tube inside.
His head just did that.
We got the message tube!
Okay, interesting.
This game is originally for the N64.
The game was so unplayable that Nintendo needed to save it.
There used to be a knight and military soldier section that got cut.
There's footage of... Oh my god, seriously?
An antique leather-bound message tube.
The kind used to transport sealed message squares.
It appears to be unopened.
There might be something inside.
Yes, open it!
Suspicions of conspiracy!
Let's go!
Oh.
What?
Pius Augustus!
Let's go.
Let's go!
Come on!
Oh, no.
Why is he so cute?
I was just thinking that, I was thinking that, he would be...
Look at his face!
He's so beautiful.
He has a beautiful mouth.
Oh, he's so cute.
Oh, my God.
Average day for Rhoda Mellon.
Oh, Charlemagne the Frank!
I like how, like, she just keeps breaking apart.
You're insane.
Or perhaps one and the other?
Just make sure he is removed from power.
Of course.
He is as good as dead.
Okay.
Why?
Why is it going on?
After the chapter page is removed, the message tube is no longer needed.
Alex discards it.
So... Oh, here's our chapter page.
Suspicions of conspiracy.
But...
Before we do that, I've noticed also our sanity meter is going down, it seems a little bit.
We still have some stuff in here.
I guess we still can't do it though.
Like the...
Where's the meter?
Is that not it right there?
The little... bubble?
Bubbly?
The bubbly?
It was here, right?
Equip the Gladius?
Can I?
Oh, I can!
Let's go.
Wait, why did you tell me to do that?
There's not gonna be dead guys in here, are there?
I sure hope not.
What's this thing?
Hmm... Hmm... This looks like it's suspiciously...
Interesting area.
That door sound...
Sounds...
So... old.
Yeah, we have to fix the key.
And we need to use the dresser key.
Hey, why is the book blinking at us over there?
Why is there an eyeball?
I just noticed it.
Um, hello?
Excuse me?
Why are we opening our eyes?
Why is everybody asleep and you are...
You're wired?
You're like...
Blink back at it?
Goodness, I'm sleepy.
Oh, let's do the suspicions of conspiracy, I suppose.
From my research, it is apparent that the endeavors of mankind...
are mere puppetry at the hands of the ancients.
Hmm...
Whenever a king vows reform, the ancients move quickly to stifle it.
Under the auspices of Emperor Charlemagne the Frank, the new Holy Roman Empire...
814.
...was at the height of its power.
France.
Assassin's Creed.
...
What is this?
Conchmit Ademinum et imperatorum nostrum.
Caralume magnum franquem.
Deliver this to our lord and emperor Charlemagne the Frank...
Ohoho, we're smarter!
No one but him must see it.
There are words for his eyes only.
Okay, what is this lighting?
Why does that background look like a...
like a Looney Tunes painted background?
This guy is just...
That guy's looking real smart.
Oh!
You're reading it!
Uh-oh.
I am bewitched!
Uh -oh!
Into the Looney Tunes!
A little hunchback of Notre Dame hours here.
They have come from Looney Tune Land!
I must speak!
After Anthony briefly describes his mission, the monk informs him that Charlemagne was last seen in audience with the bishop in the visiting chamber.
What about you?
Anthony's presence is questioned by the monks, feeling that he has trespassed upon sacred ground.
The monk seems rather subdued, perhaps out of respect, or perhaps out of fear.
Um, is this not a church?
Can't everybody come here?
I'm here to pray.
I am a holy man.
Visibly disturbed with grief and despair, the monk sobs...
Oh.
It's a funeral.
You're just a guy.
He recounts that this is not the only death to have occurred recently, and wonders if perhaps the order is being punished for a wavering in faith.
The monk cordially greets Anthony.
However, he brings grave news of the loss of one of his order, who fell from the tower to...
Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry.
He just fell?
Oh, man.
Sorry.
Sorry, mister.
I thought... I don't know.
I didn't... I just expected something else, not like...
Ah, he tripped.
And he fell.
His tone is guarded, leaving Anthony wondering if indeed this is the truth.
Oh.
I can't open the casket!
A funeral casket made from unfinished wood.
It is not properly sealed and could probably be open.
Should Anthony open the casket?
No, but yes.
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
What is he up to?
This is devil's work.
We should get out of here.
Why is everybody saying that about...
We have proven what we have feared the most.
Wait.
This poor man has been the victim of...
...great evil.
Uh-oh.
Look how his body has been defiled.
As if something has...
...burst out from inside him.
Here.
Take this for your protection.
Did they not even look at him?
And find the bishop.
He must be informed of this horrible discovery.
Did they not even...
I got this...
...scrum-a-sacks.
Scrum-a-sacks?
Scrum -a-sacks?
It has like a xenomorph.
What do you expect me to do?
I'm just a guy.
Oh, no.
I didn't get to finish talking to them.
Oh, buddy.
That a rough.
Peering inside the casket...
...Anthony sees the body of a monk.
His raiment...
Raiment is that of his order.
Stained with blood...
...that has seeped...
...from many grievous wounds.
It is a truly disturbing sight.
Anthony is voiced by Liquid Sna- Cam Clark!
And you're in a monastery...
...surrounded by monks.
Which means you have an excuse...
...to call them all brother.
Not a great track record...
...for these playable characters so far.
Do your best, Tony.
Raiment.
Raiden.
I should have quit my...
...my...
...scra...
What is this?
Message...
Oh.
Message scrolls like this...
...were often used to transfer messages securely.
This one has a strange diagram on it...
...consisting of a pentagonal shape...
...with strange letters at each corner.
Oh.
When...
...Anthony had opened the scroll...
...something strange happened.
Something had been intended...
...for the Emperor Charlemagne.
Suspecting a plot against the Emperor...
...Anthony pledged that he...
...would warn Charlemagne at all costs.
Also natural causes.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
This is all connected.
I thought I was going down a hallway.
He's not gonna get out of that...
...thing, right?
Oh.
What's over here?
Muffled voices emanate...
...from inside the Bishop's...
...visiting chamber.
However, the door is locked...
...and Anthony will need...
...the Bishop's key to enter...
...and gain an audience with...
...the Emperor Charlemagne.
Oh, you could...
...the monks could not...
...give this to me?
They knew that...
...they were like...
...oh, yeah, yeah...
...you really need to talk...
...to that guy.
Good luck.
By the way, good luck.
Yeah, just knock.
Come on, Anthony.
Use your hands.
Three minty months.
Thank you!
Charlemagne, do you like...
...my sunglasses?
Anthony cannot...
...leave yet.
Charlemagne must be...
...warned of the conspiracy...
...against him.
And also, like...
...everything that's going on...
...is kind of crazy.
What are you looking at, Anthony?
He's just really...
...powering through...
...these stairs.
Oh!
Anthony, how did you get here?
Anthony!
What did you do?
Where are we?
Anthony!
Oh, my God!
They're screaming on the ground!
Wow!
Oh, my gosh!
That's so cool!
Step, stepy, step, step, step.
It's the tome.
Cradled in what appears to be a leathery hand lies a mysterious book.
It is bound in human skin and intricately decorated with shrunken bones.
It beckons...
Shut up!
Oh, my God!
It beckons and yearns to be possessed.
Should Anthony claim the Tome of Eternal Darkness?
Uh, sure.
Anthony has acquired the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Anthony is not the same as before.
Can Anthony keep going up here?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oof!
Ouch!
What?
Oh, my God!
I'm not Anthony anymore.
Liquid Anthony!
The sound of chat was meant to do this...
Stop!
What's this?
A blue urn.
I'll take that.
I'm taking everything.
Honestly.
Anthony, you don't look so good.
I'm gonna be honest, buddy.
Oh, a mysterious gold medallion rests on the ground.
It rests upon the desk.
I'm gonna take that, too.
Oh.
Maybe not.
Oh!
He acquired a circle of power!
Anthony, are you okay?
Oh!
No way.
Describe the amount of power that a spell will have.
The more points within that circle, the stronger the spell will be.
Do we have spells now?
Spells are magical?
Why is it spelled with a K?
Magical incantations that enhance a character's natural ability.
The spell list is an inventory of all the spell information that has been acquired.
It will allow the player to select which spells to cast, examine, or assign to convenient quick spell buttons.
New spell...
Oh my gosh.
Selecting this will allow the player to experiment with rune combinations and discover new spells.
Paragon.
Is that a spell you learn?
It's not real magic.
It's magic.
It's magical.
This section is an inventory of all the components of magical spells you have acquired.
With this function, the player can review their current assignment of spells to the quick spell buttons.
Okay.
I can...
I'm a...
I'm a wizard.
Anthony, you're a wizard!
You're a wizard, Anthony.
What's in here?
Oh my god, Anthony.
You are...
You are a real jump scare.
Oh my god.
Amongst the tomes and manuscripts, a book brings attention to itself.
Oddly pristine on the dusty shelf, it doesn't quite belong.
Yeah, take the book, Anthony.
Amongst us?
A bewildering array of books and tomes sorted neatly on a set of shelves.
Mostly books of a religious nature.
They sit beneath a...
A skein?
A skein of dust.
As if no one has touched them.
Oh, sorry.
There we go.
Yo, Charlemagne.
I'm...
I can do...
I can cast spells now.
Somehow.
I'm actually not quite sure how.
Excuse me!
Is that...
Is this that Moe...
Moe magic?
Is that...
Moe magic to make Eternal Screams taste better?
Yes.
Wait, where'd my spell go?
New spell.
Anthony does not have enough components to attempt to research spells.
He can't even attempt to re...
Anthony is not smart.
Anthony can't even attempt to do anything.
Anthony, you need to take a...
Anthony.
You need to know your place, Anthony.
My god.
I only have circle runes.
I know nothing.
Level zero, mage.
Alrighty.
Climb down.
You guys, I'm gonna be honest.
I'm kind of nervous about continuing on without saving.
So I might actually cut today a little short.
Because...
If something happens and I have to play all the way back to this part...
Before stream...
I don't want to have to go through so much.
You know what I mean?
Honest.
Please be honest.
So I might actually cut today kind of short.
And then next time...
Go pretty long.
This game is so wacky but I'm having so much fun with it.
Already.
I know.
It's so...
It's such a short stream today.
But I'm gonna...
Find out what I can do.
I think I have a memory card somewhere.
I just have to...
Get it.
Find it.
Wherever.
But...
Yeah.
So next week we will continue it.
And...
Yeah.
But it was good to...
To...
Kind of...
I don't even know if I can say get a feel of this game.
Because I don't even know...
What the hell is going on.
I don't even know...
What is happening.
But it's...
Fascinating.
I will...
It's still...
You're still pretty early on.
Oh yeah.
We're barely...
We're barely in.
So...
Just a taste.
You've just entered the game proper IMO.
Mmm...
It's definitely interesting.
Thanks for the stream.
I can't wait.
Yeah.
I'm really sorry.
I will...
I will do this.
I will like Zatsu a little bit.
I know.
It's so short.
Because I don't want to just...
End the stream.
Give me a second to...
Change over...
There
we go.
Okay.
I think that'll stop the...
Oh no.
I can still hear it.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
Wait.
You guys can still even see it.
That's crazy.
I'm not gonna have it run for too long.
We'll chat...
Chat for a bit though.
For a...
Minto.
Give me one second.
I feel bad.
I feel bad that I'm like playing the game for such a short amount of time but again, I'm just really nervous.
If something happens and then I have to play back up to this point and then I'd be like I have to take all this time to play up to this point.
Let's see.
Let's put on some music.
Let's put on...
I hope you guys are liking it too even though it's like what the hell is going on.
I've seen let's players lose the hours of progress.
I know.
And I'm just nervous about it.
So it is an older game too so it's whack in a good way.
Yeah.
I was really exhausted from work this week but this stream really helped me to unwind.
Oh, Hermakity.
Thank you.
Sorry I had such a bad week.
Kiss.
So...
Bloop?
No.
We can do shorter days someday.
Sometimes.
But not maybe the best day to choose a shorter day.
I just didn't realize that I was gonna choose a shorter day.
I'm so sorry, I didn't realize the memory card.
I can't believe we just got a demo of Mint's gameplay of Eternal Darkness.
Oh my gosh, that reminds me of like when I would play...
Oh my gosh.
What was that game?
There was one demo of a game I would play all the time.
Cause I didn't own the actual thing.
It was a guy.
It was a guy that was a Skull Man from the PlayStation 1.
I can't have anything in Eternal Darkness world.
What are you talking about, Anthony?
Yes!
MedEvil!
Oh my gosh, I played the demo of MedEvil like a bajillion times.
Never played the actual game.
MedEvil!
Wait, did I spell it wrong?
Evil...
There it is.
Oh, MedEvil.
Why is it spelled like that?
Have you ever thought about streaming TTRPGs?
I don't know, I've never been like a TTRPG kind of ghost, so...
I can't really say.
I've never played them so much before.
Did I miss the gameplay?
Yes, I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Take care, Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, we're just hanging out for...
a little bit before...
I head out.
Because I don't want to also keep my GameCube running.
If I can help...
For as long as I can help it, you know?
This is the gameplay.
Yeah, a bit of a shorter stream today.
But yeah, I played MedEvil a ton.
I think...
I feel like if I name the...
I only ever had one PlayStation...
demo disc.
I feel like if I name it, people will be able to find it so easily.
Because it was MedEvil.
I don't remember if it was one or two.
It might have been two.
But it was MedEvil...
and...
Emperor's New Groove.
I played that one all the time too.
Which it had like three levels.
It had...
What did it have?
Like the village level.
And then it had...
The spider level.
And then it had this roller coaster level.
That's how often I played it.
That's how much I played it.
Because I can still remember everything.
My favorite demo disc was the one with Spyro the Dragon on it.
See, I never had Spyro 1.
But I played Spyro 2.
My first experience with MGS1 was a PS1 demo disc.
I remember it had JP voices.
No way!
I never...
You know, despite having a PlayStation 1.
I never had played Metal Gear.
Thanks for the stream, Mint!
Yippee!
Three months!
I had one with Tony Hawk.
I think mine also had Tony Hawk.
I had some sort of skateboarding game, I think.
Do you have Fortnite Raiden skin?
No!
I have...
Snake skin.
I never got Raiden skin.
I actually couldn't figure out how to get Raiden skin on Fortnite.
I have Snake and I tried to get Old Snake.
But it was too difficult.
I wasn't...
I wasn't gamer enough.
Nah.
Raiden was just one you buy.
But it wasn't showing up in my store.
Emulators of the older games.
Yeah, yeah.
True.
I used to swap in and out of demo discs in my PS1.
While the motor was still spinning.
In order to import games.
What?
One day it shattered in my hand and forced me to find a better way.
Was your hand okay?
Was your PlayStation okay?
What shattered?
What are you talking about?
I didn't even know you could do that.
Wait, we're back in the day where games region locked?
Like that?
Cause...
They were?
No way!
PS1 and PS2 were region locked.
Seriously?
What?
Let's see.
Nowadays, it's like...
Getting...
I think the last thing that I can think of that was region locked was like the 3DS.
I can't...
Think of...
Unless I'm...
Unless I'm just dumb.
Could be PlayStation Magazine Demo Disc 44.
Which also had MGS1.
No way.
Don't tell me that.
Hold on.
I'm gonna go look it up.
PS Magazine Demo Disc 44.
Wait.
But the magazine looks familiar.
Hold on.
Don't tell me that I had Metal Gear this whole time.
No.
Hold on.
No no no.
No.
This didn't...
No!
No no no.
This isn't...
No cause this doesn't even have Media Ball.
Watch the Let's Play of Eternal Darkness over 11 years ago according to YouTube and forgot about it ever since.
The weirdness is all coming back to me.
So...
Where is it?
That's definitely... weird.
When I was like 10, my brother had my mom drive us an hour to buy Eternal Darkness from a GameStop that had it.
It's really amazing to see you play.
I've always wanted to see more of the game when I was a kid.
Oh, awesome!
Glad that we can be fulfilling these...
childhood... these childhood dreams, right?
It has medieval?
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, the magazine is showing... oh, wait.
Wait, no, but it's showing me on the magazine.
It's showing like Baldur's Gate and Ace Combat 4.
I can't see what's on the disc.
I can't tell.
The disc is too small.
The pictures are too small.
Wait a second, hold on.
Oh, wait.
Disney's Emperor New Groove?
Ape Escape?
Medieval 2?
Metal Gear Solid?
No, no, no.
PlayStation?
PlayStation demo disc.
Emperor's New Groove.
No, I found it!
I found the one that I had!
Wait, hold on.
It has...
It wasn't... okay, I found it.
I found it.
Because I... it was... hold on, I'll save the image.
It doesn't have Metal Gear.
I was like this... the... what's it called?
The thing itself?
Like the disc itself looked familiar, but I think because this was the disc.
And it had...
Oh my gosh, it's so hard to read.
Yeah, it had Medieval 2 also on it, and the Emperor's New Groove.
Oh, I was pro BMX that I was thinking of.
It was not... it was pro BMX.
I knew it was like some sort of sports game... not sports, but you know, like...
I was like, it's either... it's either...
Skateboarding... Oh, it did have skateboarding!
Grind Session!
Yeah, this is the... this is the exact one I had.
Because I recognized the...
The...
The sleeve.
Dang.
Oh my gosh, though.
Can you imagine?
I was one step away from glory.
I was... if I had just got the magazine one...
I don't even know how I got this one.
But if I had just gotten the magazine one...
I would have...
I would have had Metal Gear!
And Ape Escape!
Have you ever checked the Snake Sam Fisher Death Battle?
What?
Dad Mint got it, maybe?
Maybe, yeah.
Did you get it from Pizza Hut?
Oh, maybe.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I just... it's just in my memory.
I do not have a way of how I acquired it.
I used to even play MLB.
I just realized that the...
That the dates of the games really kind of exposed me.
Oh,
what should it be?
Forgetty Spaghetti.
Everybody.
It's a... it's fine.
I'm a ghost.
I've been around for a while.
It's fine.
I'm a ghost.
Here in similar company.
Yippee!
Do we all have our bad PS1 era sports?
Sports games?
I would play... yeah, I would play the MLB one.
I played Grind Session.
I played Medieval a lot.
I loved Medieval.
And I loved the Emperor's New Groove game.
Played that one a lot too.
But... oh my gosh.
Even on the back of the box, it shows the spider level that I talked about.
Oh...
Yeah.
I can't believe that I almost had Metal Gear.
But I don't remember ever buying like the...
The magazines.
Not even my dad got them, so...
Not even my dad got them, but now I want to find it.
PlayStation Magazine Demo Disc 44.
4-4!
It's even lucky for me!
4 is such a spooky number!
To think there are PS1 demo discs floating around with the Titan AE game demo.
It's the only way to play that game since the full game was cancelled.
Really?
Did you try games by renting them at Blockbuster?
Sometimes.
I'm trying to think of what games I...
You know, I'll be honest, like completely...
I think because I didn't play so many games when I was a kid...
Is because I was obsessed with Pokemon.
And that was all I wanted to play.
All I wanted to play was Pokemon!
And so I really didn't branch out so much more.
I had other games.
But I just always just...
I would...
I would go to the bathroom with my Game Boy and pretend that like...
I was pooping for hours.
My mom would be like, Are you okay in there, Mint?
I'd be like, Yeah, my tummy hurts!
I'm just...
I'm like...
Aunt Sabrina.
Death Battle is a YouTube channel.
They animate fights between characters.
Ah!
Check it out!
Sasuga.
Yeah.
And then...
You know, I would watch my dad play games.
He'd like to play a lot of stuff.
And...
Uh...
I had an N64.
I only saw demo discs through friends.
I didn't have...
I only had the PlayStation.
Well, I had PlayStation and Game Boy.
That's what...
That might...
I actually...
Well, all my stuff was like hand-me-downs from my sisters.
And so...
My sister, she had a...
Sega Nomad.
So I got to play games from that because of her.
So...
Um...
But...
That's...
You had a Sega Nomad?
I know, right?
I almost got...
I almost said the Sega Genesis.
I was like, no, no.
What was it called?
The Nomad.
The Nomad was the portable one.
I think I might still have it somewhere.
And I had...
I basically...
I only had the Sonic games.
The Lion King game.
I thought about playing that recently.
I was like, I should...
Oh, I had Echo the Dolphin.
That is my trauma.
It's my actual trauma.
It is a Genesis, but portable.
Right, right, right.
It's like huge.
I had even a battery pack for the back.
And...
It like...
It took like seven batteries or something.
It was crazy.
Return to the ocean.
Well, I just...
I don't like...
I don't like stealth.
I don't like stealth games.
Metal Gear is my...
Is my exception.
Baby Koi.
Thanks for the gift.
I really don't like stealth, though.
I really kind of took a gamble.
Like truly, I don't know why I played Metal Gear.
But rather...
When I started with Revengeance, I was like...
This seems like a silly game.
And it was before like the big hype and everything happened.
And even then, I was so like...
You know, that was fun.
I don't actually know why I started Metal Gear.
And...
Have you considered playing Devil May Cry games?
Yes!
That's on my list for sure.
Playing MGS1 demo in the 90s was so mind-blowing.
I truly don't know why, because like I said, I hate stealth.
I think I just kind of was like...
At the time, thinking...
This is a game series that is so influential and...
You know, everybody knows about Snake and his...
Clapping cheeks.
And I was like, I kind of want to know more about that.
And then...
It all...
Snowballed and went downhill.
And now...
I'm where I am.
And my brain...
My brain chemistry has been...
Forever altered.
Moira!
Welcome to membership!
The memes got her.
I don't even think it was me being like...
Oh, I want to know more about...
What they were talking about in Revengeance.
Because I'll be honest...
I mean, I was so confused.
But...
Even thinking about it now, I don't think that's so much connected.
They talk about the Patriots.
The Patriots a little bit, but...
I think it's true.
What about some PS1 action games?
Chase the Express.
It's like a Tom Cruise game...
Film as a game.
Parasite Eve!
Oh my gosh.
I always wanted to play Parasite Eve...
Forever ago.
So glad you're here!
Kazami, thank you!
Mintpie, thank you!
MG...
Fan...
Stom...
True.
Truest words...
Ever spoken.
A little pause... and we are back.
I'm going to play some other games that you don't see so many people streaming very often because at the time, like nobody was streaming Metal Gear.
You had Pekora who streamed it before.
And I didn't even get to watch her VODs because they all got removed.
But now she's replayed them.
But I'm just kind of like...
It's kind of just like...
I think my chat's delayed.
Wait, I think my everything is delayed.
Uh-oh, hold on.
One second.
I'm refreshing.
There we go.
But yeah, so I've just been trying to, you know, like with this game as well, just trying to get through some things that maybe people don't touch as much in terms of VTuber playthroughs.
Her site Eve is actually based on a JP novel.
Oh, is it really?
Oh my gosh, my chat is all messed up.
Everything's all messed up.
After the release of Ace Combat 7 for the Switch Bandai already announced merch for the games.
I'm so excited.
They got a JPEG dog sticker.
No way!
MGS, Mintos, great streams.
Oh my gosh, that reminds me.
I was on AmiAmi last night.
And guys, hold on.
I have to... I have to... I already have it up.
I already have it pulled up.
Look!
Look at this!
I saw this last night and I nearly screamed.
Outer Wilds!
Archaeologist Edition!
Oh my gosh, look!
Oh my god.
And then also the AmiAmi Gente item.
If you pre-order from AmiAmi, you can also get an acrylic key holder.
But also the ones that are... Look how cute!
And the middle thing is like a... It says it's a fabric poster.
Rather than like a wall scroll.
But it's probably... You know, you can make it into a wall scroll.
So...
Your game choices are really interesting and fun.
I look forward to them.
Thank you!
YouTube, why?
Yeah, I'm sorry.
It's all like kind of... Chat is all kind of delayed and stuff.
I thought it was just me.
I think my stream is all messed up.
Like it's all delayed.
But yeah, isn't it so cute?
It comes with the little key chains.
And then the...
And it also comes with the DLC.
I love Outer Wilds.
I was like, oh no, I guess I'll have to buy it.
I ordered the limited edition from IM8Bit.
Of Outer Wilds?
It has the fabric bag.
Wait.
IM8Bit.
I'm going.
I'm viewing.
What?
The bag is so cool!
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
Hold on, I'll show you guys a picture.
Property of Outer Wilds Ventures!
No way!
This is the one you were talking about?
I don't understand the scar... like the ascot though.
Art, not vinyl.
I don't really understand that.
But the book looks really cool.
All the little badges and stuff of the different planets are really cute.
So this is the archaeologist edition but in...
In... Western.
I suppose.
Try Ninja Turtles games.
Bet nobody does that.
Ninja Turtles.
Oh yeah, there's a kazoo down there too.
It's so cute.
Wow.
Oh wait, it says...
Canvas Traveler's Adventure Bag.
Explorer's Journal plus Game Sleeve.
Oh, so it's not like an art book.
It's a journal.
Oh, it's Church's Bandana!
Set of seven planetary patches.
Bonus item from a doomed timeline.
Eye of the Universe Clasp.
Base game plus Echoes of the Eye expansion.
Region free.
Worldwide capability.
So the...
The kazoo is the bonus item?
It's not even like...
It's like all blacked out.
Ace Combat Seven Seekers is going to be on Rakuten JP website.
And then there's F16 model kit.
Wait I wonder...
I wonder if AmiAmi will have a special pre-order item too.
Not the Doom kazoo!
Can't wait for you to play Xenoblade eventually.
Eventually!
It is on the list.
It is on the list!
Of stuff.
We'll get there, we'll get there.
Eventually.
Oh my gosh, shut up, they have... Oh no!
No!
This I Am 8-Bit Place had vinyl soundtracks!
Oh my gosh, I bought one Metal Gear vinyl and now I got the Steins Gate vinyl and...
Oh, but they're sold out!
Oh my gosh, I would cry though, I would put it on and I would cry.
No!
I think Outer Wilds is like, to me even more so a super special series because...
It was one of the last things I played back in heaven and so...
You know, and the ending is just so like...
And so to me it just means, it just like has such a special meaning.
That I...
Like...
What was the word?
I...
Um...
Have good memories with it, you know?
Did you buy a turntable yet?
No, not yet!
I honestly, I wasn't gonna get one until the Metal Gear ones shipped but...
Um...
They...
Sold...
Uh...
They sold the Steins Gate ones at the Jast booth at AX and so I got that.
And...
So now I actually have something like that.
And that's worth...
That will need a turntable.
It's an ending and a new beginning.
Yeah.
Outer Wilds music still makes me tear up and it's been years.
It's so...
It's so weird.
Acceptance of an end that brings a new beginning.
Fitting, huh?
Yeah, somehow.
Somehow it ended up that way.
Oh, and they also had a vinyl soundtrack that was a pre-order of Echoes of the Eye music.
But isn't that, like, kind of creepy?
It says, Secrets from the Outer Wilds.
Read at your own risk.
It's so cool!
Wow, the art is...
The art goes hard.
Look at this.
Actually, this is, like, so genius.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
I have to save it like this.
Oh, hold on.
Actually, let me do this.
Um...
Whoop.
Uh...
One second.
I'm getting your pictures.
Okay, so this is the...
This one's so sweet!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm getting your pictures.
So you could say...
Oh, sorry.
They're different sizes.
Save.
Okay, here we go.
Um...
Okay.
I'm so sad that they're sold out, though.
But the one on the right is from, like, you know, obviously it's...
It's the Outer Wilds proper.
And then the one on the left is from the...
Is from the, um...
DLC.
But it's so cool because, like...
They have, like, the part that's...
Like, it looks like the vinyl is ripped and then it shows the secret planet.
It looks so cool!
Oh, the covers are so nice.
The left one looks so cool.
I know!
Such a cool sleeve.
I'm so glad and understandable that Outer Wilds means that much to you as well.
It's been one of my favorite series to watch you play.
Thank you, Nexi!
Ghostbusters, the video game.
2009.
Busted.
I...
Oh, my gosh.
Every time I'm on the plane, I always see Ghostbusters and I'm like, I should watch it.
It's been, like...
I think I've only watched it ever once.
And it was, you know, probably when I was a kid.
But I don't think I can watch it without, like...
Without Busted.
Like, the song is just ruined for me.
I can't do the original anymore.
The original song.
Watch-a-long?
October watch-a-long?
Maybe.
It got the Ghostbusters brain rot.
I don't think it goes that hard.
Okay.
Oh, Neil Ciciarga Remix is a straight up improvement.
It's just so funny.
Such a good... such a good.
Speaking of, thank you guys for hanging out with me today, as always.
Thank you for... again, I know I keep apologizing, but I feel so bad.
I wanted to keep playing for real, but I was just nervous.
That if I have to start over... I don't want to start over.
I don't wanna go through the two hours again.
Even though I know what to do now, I could've...
But if I have to, I can.
And then I could just... I'm gonna try and figure it out.
And again, if I have to...
If I can't figure out a way to save it...
I will make the next stream an endurance stream.
So I can at least beat it.
And then maybe...
We'll do like a...
You could find new things.
Oh my gosh, we could save that guy!
Came in kind of late.
I don't know what's going on.
It's fine.
But yeah.
You cut it close at the temple, so it was a good decision.
I know.
It's just gonna get harder too, right?
But I gamed a little bit.
I gamed a little bit.
Endurance, woo!
I don't think I'll do all three endings.
Maybe I'll do one of them and then we watch the other two.
Or...
It's not three endings.
I play it three times and then I...
Watch it.
I don't know.
I'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
As we do.
Anyway.
Better safe than sorry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, next stream.
Next couple of days.
I'll get it.
Well, hopefully next couple of days.
I'll get it figured out.
I promise.
I promise!
It's my brain.
I didn't even think about it.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Everybody.
Thank you.
It is time.
To do.
Our.
Goodbye ritual.
And that we will be.
Bustin' together.
Bustin'.
Oh my god!
It's loud.
Otsu Bustin'.
Otsu Mito.
There's
something strange.
Sleeping in your bed.
Dun dun dun laddub.
Let me tell you something.
If there's something we're sleeping in your bed.
Oh!
Let me tell you some.
Ow.
Oh.
Push it.
Push m.
I'm obsessed with the OWWWWWWWW!
B-b-b-bustin'!
Seein' things...
Sleepin' in your bed...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Invisible man!
Sleepin' in your bed!
Ow!!!
Let me tell you something.
OW!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good...
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin'...
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good...
Feel good!
Freaky ghost maid!
Freaky ghost man!
Freaky man, baby!
If you're all alone, let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good!
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
I like the freaky music here.
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost man!
I forgot to mention, tomorrow will be a membership stream.
I think I do...
Karaoke.
If you are a member, you will get a membership karaoke stream.
I'll make the waiting room right after this.
A kiss!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you guys!
Feel good!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Thanks for the ten gifted!
Thank you guys for the stream!
Again, I'm so sorry that it was so short.
Oh my goodness.
I'm too big!
I'm trying to scroll up.
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thanks for the ten gifted!
Oh my gosh!
There's too many!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thanks for the five
gifted!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Star creator!
Thanks for the ten gifted!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god!
There's so many!
I have to play it again.
Okay, so you're after 6 of the 5 gifted...
Mr. Albee, is he next for the 10 gifted?
And Draco, is he next for the 10 gifted?
Zazamo, is he next for the 10 gifted?
Hi!
Mr. Mark, is he next for the 10 gifted?
Wow!
Rice Knot, right?
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Snacksy, thanks for the 10!
I'd rather not, thanks for the 10!
Is that ketchup?
Yuki, thanks for the 10!
Bustan, Bustan, Bustan!
And Draco, thanks for the 10!
Thanks for the 10!
Superliminal, thanks for the 10!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Rockford Rabbit, thanks for the 10!
Pulsaranger, thanks for the 10!
I've been in your bed!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Jay!
Thanks for the 10!
Ow!
SilverNuclear, thanks for the 10!
You guys, please!
Gumball, thanks for the 10!
NotoriousBruceG!
Thanks for the gifted!
Clockwork, thanks for the 10!
Chat, is this real?
I don't know.
FightSize, thanks for the 3, man!
Okay.
TroyPrincess, thanks for the 5!
Gifted, thank you!
FreakyGhostman!
Pyrobook, thanks for the 10!
Larry, thanks for the 5!
FreakyMan, baby!
Clockwork, thanks for the 10!
Goodnight, man.
Goodnight, 9.
Hahaha.
Phew!
FightSize, thanks for the 10!
Let me tell you something.
Sleepin' makes me feel good!
MBK, thanks for the 10!
RustinGlitchBase, thanks for the 5!
I don't feel like I can end it.
Because I don't want to cut off the song.
Ronaldo, thanks for the 5!
An invisible bed...
FreakyGhost memberships!
I mean, gifted memberships.
Miss, thank you for the 10!
We're just... we're... we're...
Freaky... FreakyGhost...
Oh.
Wrong thing.
Taisee, thanks for the 10!
Gifted!
You guys don't have to give gifted.
It's okay.
You guys don't.
Taisee, thanks for the 5!
It's okay.
We can just vibe to the music.
It's alright.
It is a ghost membership.
Giften makes us feel good.
Thank you for the 20!
You already did so many though.
Okay,
no gifted.
Okay, no gifted.
Moitak, welcome!
Tonwin, thank you for the 5!
JPNG, thanks for the 5!
Bustin, Bustin, C2, thank you for the 5!
Don't tell me what to do.
Valentine, thanks for the 20!
Hi, it's me!
Welcome back!
Okay, I'm out of here.
Bye!
Thank you guys, thank you.
Bye-bye!
Mr. Opium, thank you for the 5!
Bloodlust, thank you for the 10!
SilverNuclear, thank you for the 10!
Okay.
Otomito!
Give it a little...